Tom Brady said afterwards that you  deserved the MVP they gave him the MVP  he said you deserve the MVP that must  have felt really nice oh that felt nice  but I mean I wouldn't get 14 catches if  he wasn't throwing me the ball so I mean  he's more than more than well deserving  of that award he's our leader any reason  we fought back into that game I mean  it's very nice but Brandon did say Brady  did say that you deserved you actually  his quote was I think that he would have  given you the MVP truck and this is kind  of nice because Ford agreed with Brady  so here it is it's all yours the Ford  f-150 the official truck of the Super  Bowl right over here  [Applause]  this is your truck  beautiful that's beautiful gorgeous  that's awesome that's right you can have  this truck for 24 hours no it's yours  now he's got a drive back now you got a  ride back to Boston yeah we'll go with  you no I'm so happy for you a Superbowl  champion James way congratulations  you